豊臣秀幸 天下一のぶっ飛びマシーン 千葉県出身
織田慎太郎 セオリー無視の一発屋 千葉県出身
徳川泰兵衛 麻雀理論を全く持たない タコなき男 千葉県出身
明智光一 超合理的理論麻雀を打つ 試合校舎 千葉県出身
早見明一郎豊臣の恋人
驚異的なツキの持ち主
千葉県出身
チャイ
ヤス
タバコあるか
ほう。
これ、ちゃんと後で返すだよ。
分かってるよ。
今日も元気なタバコが美味い。
なんだ、慎太郎。
今日はやけに機嫌がいいだっぺ。
実は俺も、妙に心が晴れ晴れとしてんだ。
そうかよ。本当、ウトラもそうだっぺよ。
そうか?
あのー、ウソッコを切ったんだけど。
ローンメンチ!
ローンダブラン三眼光!
ローンピンク三色ドラドラ!
次は!
腹減った
この三日間、水しか飲んでおらん。
はい、豊臣ですが。
秀幸かい?
おがん!
元気でやってるかい?
げ、元気、元気だよ。
昨日、野菜とみかん、宅配便で送ったからね。
本当?
体だけは気をつけて頑張っとくれよ。
どうも、どうも。
来たぞ
今だ
わー
次ラミーンディアンの襲撃だ
こうして救援物資はトヨタミの手元までは届かなかった
はーい
あ、アギナじゃ
トヨタミ君
あきなちゃん、ありがとう。
ううん、こんなことぐらい。
ねえ、豊臣くん。
なに、あきなちゃん。
私、私、アメリカに留学することになったの。
教授がぜひ行って来いって、うちの両親も賛成してくれてるの
そ、そんな
たぶん、卒業してもしばらくは向こうにいることになると思う
そ、そう、なんて言ったらいいのかな、おめでとうかな、やっぱり
今まで本当にありがとう、豊臣くん
来て
私ね、東京へ来てまたあなたに会えてとっても楽しかった
一緒にアメリカに来て、豊臣くん
向こうにはジャンソーなんてないんだろうな
でも、それは無理よね
でも私、麻雀絶対に忘れない
いつかまたきっと
豊臣君と一緒に
麻雀を出るわよね
出発は
明後日の夕方の5時の
サンフランシスコ行きの
ユナイテッド
明後日
今日まで言い出せなくてごめんなさい
あの
お願いがあるの
空港まで見送りに来て
これが
あなたに言える私の最後の
わがままね
秋名ちゃん
私がアメリカに行ってる間に
あなたは変わるし
私も変わるわ
待っててなんてとても
とても言えない
決めた
何しとるんですか
師匠
いきなり身近くなんかして
どないしはったんや
俺アメリカに行く
なんやて
ワイボー行きますアメリカ
バーカ
遊びに行くんじゃない
向こうで暮らすんだ
それにお前の料理なんかどこにもないぞ
師匠そんな摂取をな
豊臣
すまない聞かせてもらったぞ
おめえ今アメリカって
アメリカっつうのは千葉より遠いとこだっぺ
説明してもらおうか
そうか
お前たちにも連絡しようと思ってたんだ
ちょうどいい
明日の夕方
俺は日本を絶つ
だからお前らとももうお別れだ
おめえ一人じゃねえな
なるほど
ハヤミと一緒か
カモが海渡って
アメリカさ行くってか
ヤス
お前にしちゃシャレたこと言うじゃねえか
いや俺も決めっとこ決めねえとよ
勝負は明日の勝負
ここで最後のハンチョンだ
望むところだ
そうか
最後の勝負を
お前はもう
技術的にはもう誰とやっても
それなりの勝負ができよう
はい
あとは己の自信じゃ
自信を持て
お前は勝てる
豊臣春は好きか
お前はまっすぐな心を持っておる
麻雀というものはな
最後にはまっすぐな心が勝つのじゃ
よいか豊臣
お前の今までのつかんぽは
すべてこのエピローグを盛り上げるための
除去に過ぎなかったのじゃ
精進性よ
コウちゃん コーヒー入ったわよ
コウちゃん
ねえ コウちゃんってば
アメリカ…ったら…
総武戦かよ?
それとも、序盤戦だったかよ?
モンガイさん、この勝負は、どうしても勝ちたいんです!
それより、そのアメリカに行くアキナちゃんをよ。
お前が男として、これから幸せにしてやれるかどうかだろうが。
もし強い男なら幸せにしてやれる。弱ければダメだ。
お前が麻雀で負けるのは月がないからじゃねえ
男として弱いからなんだ
確かにあの三人はお前にとって大きな壁だ
だがその壁を倒さなきゃ
所詮お前は男にはなれねえ
負けたら死ぬ
そういうギリギリの気持ちで勝負できるかどうかなんだ
パパプロにも会っておくか
兄さん おやりだぜ 早く切れよ
どないしてんよ 早く切れな
ま いいか
はい はやみです
トヨタミ君
明日、奴らと最後の麻雀を打ちます
もし、それに勝ったら
勝ったら?
君と一緒にアメリカに行く
でも、もし負けたら
行くだけの価値のない男だと思ってください
分かったわ、トヨタミ君
その勝負、勝ってね
頑張ってね
きっと、きっと勝ってね!
やあ、待ってたよ。
ご苦労さんです。
-おう!-おう!
早速、始めようか。
バギメはいつもの通り、つかみ取りで行くぜ。
トンカ、俺、ここがいいな。
じゃん、な、ここだな。
ここは前に豊臣から酷使上がった席だ!
そういや、俺もここで豊臣から大惨げ上がったことあるぜ。
俺も確かここで数あんこ上がったっけな。
どの席も振ってるさ!
だけどもうそれは過去のことだぜ!
心置きなくやらせてもらうぜ。
ああ。
んだっぺ!
師匠。
お三方 最後の勝負
亡きのダボケンことこのケンジンが
死価と見届けさせてもらいます
思う存分 打っておくんな ハレ
それじゃあ 始めるぜ
そして サイは投げられた
ドラはないし
ここは2,3,4の3式目を狙う一手か
リーチ
来い来い
先生リーチには慣れてるぜ
明智もテンパったか
ほらこのパターンだ
三腕、数腕は、慎太郎に現物だ。
弱気に出て三腕を斬れば、明智に満眼。
強気で数素か老素を斬れば、慎太郎に残苦を振り込む。
ならば、これか!
チー!
ヤスは親だから泣いて憎く、ツーロパーソからのカンチーソ町か?
出た!
ジョーン!ハクドラさん、8000点!
ああ、おや、流れちまったな!
かあ!いねえか、この灰!
わかる!わかるぜ!
お前らの麻雀が、手に取るように、わかる!
あった!ドラはパーワンか
なんでリーチかけへんのや?師匠
椅子そってんぱいやないか
あれ?
椅子そてないな
やはりどこかに固まってるのか
リーチ
リーチだよリーチ
何やってんだ俺は
こんな手玉で回してるなんて
リーチ
投資
叩き合おうぜ
野郎つもらん
裏こい
触れ、豊臣!
いつものように触れ!それがおめえの宿命だ!
リーチ一発ツモ!ピンフドライチ!
このイーソー、もしかしてラスハイか?
ラスハイだぜ!くそ!ツモるかよ、そんなの!
豊臣くん…
サン・フランシスコ1機、401便の搭乗手続きの受け付けを開始致します。
ユナイタティニオン航空、サン・フランシスコ1機、401便の搭乗手続きの受け付けを開始致します。
わっしゃー!慎太郎班にリーチ勝ちですやん!
そうさ!慎太郎にはいつも積もられてたからな!
ち、ち、ほ、ほ!
これいらないっぺ
あたってみるぜ
トン三色ドラドラ高め
ありがと
ヤッサンにも泣きがちましたやん
所詮あいつはたこ泣き男
俺の方が実力は上なのさ
ここはやはりパワーギリ
ゴロッチの三色狙いか
勝った
ロン
待ってたぜその灰が出るの
なんちゅん本一ちゃんたはねまんや
こんなはずじゃねえぞ
なんか展開が変だよ
トヨタミ
煩悩を捨てるのじゃ
無心じゃ
無心で勝負に挑むのじゃ
よいか、トヨトミ!
ロン、一発!
トヨトミ、男の強さは展望にあらわれるものだぜ。
ロー、メタペン、エイペク、ドラゴン!
ラン
あと3000点しかねえだよ
俺あと2000
俺あと1200
よいしょラス
ラス親だ
あ、あかん、あきなはんのひこうきのしゅっぱつはたしか5じのはずや
あ、し、ししょうがもえとる
ししょうがまっかにもえとる
だめや、わいにはとてもはなしかけられへん
きた
ほいろといといなん、さんしょくどうこう
おやっぱねてんぱいや
思い出すぜ、お前らに散々はめられた日々
今こそ、三人一遍に飛ばしてやるぜ
この、この六千オールでな!
待ってて、秋田ちゃん!
豊臣くん
お客様、お早くどうぞ
ええ
ローン スウォンコウタンキ
ローン ダイサンゲン
ローン メンチンピンフタンヤオ ビャンペイコウドラドラ
やったトップだよ
2着か
ついてねこの手上がって3着止まりかよ
ただいま、当401便は新東京国際空港を帝国通りに離陸いたしました。
ティーオーカフィー?
ティープリース?
ジーザス!スーパーマンだ!
- ツカンコだよ! ツカンコは素晴らしいよ!
豊臣くん、来てくれたのね!
また、一緒に遊べるのね!
チカンポ
豊臣くん、大好きよ!
豊臣くん!
やろう、とうとう俺たちの借金残したまま行っちまったな
ああ、あっちがアメリカだ
で、こっちがチンバだ
また一人、若えのが旅されてるだな
じっちゃん デーダーがでけえ漁師を見っけっけえよ 急ぐだよ
おいよ
師匠 師匠 わいはこれから一人でどない生きていきゃいいんでか
師匠
こうして若者は旅立った
三人の友と一人の弟子とありあまるほどの感動と思い出を残して
また会おうトヨトミ
いつの日かきっと
ご視聴ありがとうございました
幸せ 掴もうよ
嫌いでヤバいのまんまんどころ
飛んで 早くなさくなるの
ここは三面町どころ
行くな カンキャン
徳島そこの責が派だ
相撲にも負けんくんにやりづいて
勝って飲み越すビールがうまい
スカルトン!お酒は命がけ!
スカルトン!スカルトン!
ガキカメット!ガガンガンガンガンガンガン!
ご視聴ありがとうございました